monsieur el bacha bonjour merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france à
l'heure où on a senti qu'il y avait eu
plusieurs jours d'hésitation de la part
du gouvernement quant à la stratégie à
adopter face à la pandémie finalement
c'est le repos finement qui a été
décrétée pour qu'un jour nouveau
confinement justement était inévitable
selon vous bonjour médicalement oui les
structures de santé sont totalement
pratiquement saturé on a deux centres
282 200 272 patients dans les urgences
on a une petite dizaine de décès
quotidiens c'est comme ça que ça assure
entre guillemets renouvellement mais les
structures médicales sont saturés on a
quarante mille cas actifs aux cinquante
mille cas de personnes guéries donc c
est l'autre paramètre importe important
à souligner c'est que le liban est au
deuxième rang mondial au niveau des pays
ayant le plus d'hospitalisations cent
mille habitants on est à trois points 5
personnes pour 100000 habitants
hospitalisés qu'en raison de la belgique
4.9 et figure au premier rang comment
ont réagi les libanais on sait qu'il n'y
a actuellement une instabilité politique
qui dure une crise économique sans
précédent
après notamment les explosions au port
de beyrouth en août dernier c'est un
coup de massue de trop pour pour les
libanais les libanais s'y attendait un
peu
il y avait il ya une résistance contre
le confinement d'un d'une part des
organismes économiques de certaines
personnes et une résignation de l'autre
côté
en fait le liban comme vous le savez est
intacte et par une crise économique qui
a commencé déjà avant le col vide dès
l'année dernière on a entre temps eu un
état de défauts de paiement avec les
conséquences que ça sur la situation
socio économique même si on exclut et le
coronavirus et depuis on a eu aussi
l'explosion du port de beyrouth
et donc c'est très dur en fait de le
faire la différence entre les différents
effets et ainsi de suite donc le
certains ont tendance à dire ces accros
du coronavirus sans voir le reste des
paramètres qui rend et des facteurs qui
rentrent en jeu dans la gradation de
l'activité économique et les gens
craignent pour leur emploi aujourd'hui
voilà mon à 29% des libanais qui ont eu
une perte d'emploi enfin la population
active qui a eu une perte d'emplois
presque au vide on sait pas exactement
si c'est lui à la détérioration de la
situation économique à l'explosion du
port ou encore au corona virus est là
justement on parlait de cette crise
économique avec la mise en place de ce
confinement est ce un petit peu la mise
à mort de l'économie libanaise puisque
là aussi les commerces vont être obligés
de fermer alors que la situation ne s'y
prête pas dans un cas normal la courte
heure oui on a des baisses on a on le
les projections de croissance était de
14% avant 14 à 17% avant la clio
qu'ovide maintenant on est à -24% de
récession économique
donc quand on a un impact mais il faut
1000 fois aussi on n'arrive pas vraiment
à extrait à aix d'avoir quelle est la
part des choses de chaque chose il ya
une sorte de choses très imbriqué dans
les unes dans les autres
pour revenir à votre question en fait il
y aura probablement des conséquences
importantes les gens ont peur voilà on
sait que l'association des commerçants
par de beyrouth rejette justement ce
confinement pas seulement celle de
tripoli les industriels
normalement dans un cas normal après le
confinement on aurait un phénomène de
rattrapage
cependant au liban on a aussi les
banques qui ont installé par exemple un
contrôle des capitaux
donc on n'a pas accès à l'épargné dont
même après le confinement à risque
la situation risque encore plus de se
prolonger ça c'est d'une part d'autre
part il ya aussi un message paradoxal au
niveau des autorités politiques et
monétaires
les autorités politiques veulent mettre
en place un filet à un programme de
filet de sauvetage social de 1200
milliards de livres libanaises au taux
de parité officiel c'est un peu près 800
millions de dollars autour officieux
c'est 160 millions de dollars
donc on voit déjà la dégradation du
pouvoir d'achat et de l'autre côté la
banque du liban qui essaye de limiter la
masse monétaire en limitant l'accès aux
dépôts et les banques en limite qui
limite aussi l'accès aux dépôts en
dollar avec un contrôle informel des
capitaux donc on n'aura pas cet effet de
rattrapage dans l'économie lieu hausse
par rapport à cela
tout simplement parce que on n'a pas
accès à l'épargnant n'a pas accès à
l'argent enfin bon on ne croit pas de
consommer on ne va pas relancer
l'économie même après confinement
dernière question mais très très
rapidement monsieur françois el bacha ou
sais combien c'est difficile
actuellement au liban avec cette
instabilité politique et la difficulté
de mettre à un gouvernement placé ce que
vous pensez que les libanais vont
respecter ce confinement
ils n'ont pas respecté précédemment le
confinement d'une manière très
disciplinée et il ya eu beaucoup de
résistants je vois pas aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qui pourrait les amener à
respecter le confinement à venir c'est
toute la problématique
l'état est faible et très faible
économiquement et caetera et l'état est
faible aussi d'un point de vue de
sanitaires merci beaucoup en tout cas
françois el bacha d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
économiste est confondant cofondateur
pardon du site alibaba